This box has been in my cupboard a long time though,
this box is much older than most of the other stuff,
because I brought this when I was a school boy,
and it is travel around with me in this box.
There are some souvenirs of my grandfather.
The discharge is because they are tubes for electrical discharge.
I'll just show you this one because it stands up.
You can see it's a piece of quite ornate glassware.
And if you look, there are a number of features that you can see.
It has been sealed off here and here by
putting a torch. So it was sealed with a vacuum or gas in it,
and there's a narrow tube going inside,
which goes round and round and round and so on.
And then they used to be an electrode at the top.
Now there's just a bit of wire and there's an electrode at the front.
This is an example of what is called a Geisler tube named of the
German physicist called Geisler who invented this in 1857.
It belonged with the other two to my grandfather,
my grandfather,
who was called Joseph Poliakoff was an extraordinarily talented inventor.
He had, I don't know how many patents in his lifetime.
He invented the volume control, which is now on every radio.
He invented the hearing loop,
which helps deaf people here in concert halls and
so on and lots of other things as well.
He also invented an early form of the transistor in the
1920s, but why he had these? I don't know.
I think he probably just thought they were fun. And if you look at the glass,
the glass is slightly yellow because it's impregnated with some
sort of iron, which fluoresces when exposed to UV light.
The point about these Geisla tubes is that they filled with a low pressure of
gas. Unfortunately,
I don't know which sort of gas it's definitely not neon because neon would play
red. It may be air. It could be air with a trace of mercury.
But the important thing about these gases are that when you apply a high
voltage,
you used a device called a Tesla coil named after the famous
scientist, Tesla,
which produces a very high voltage at a very high
frequency.
It's sufficient,
certainly high that it can jump across narrow gaps of insulators
like air.
And what is to me even now remarkable is that if you apply them to these,
you get to discharge to generate a plasma in the gas without having
to have any electrical connection to the other.
Presumably there is enough current that will leak either through the glass
or to earth through the air.
The mechanism is the high voltage ionizes, the gas,
the ions recombine, and give out energy.
This makes the gas hot and it emits light.
Not necessarily just because it's hot, but because the electron,
as it falls back to the nucleus or to the energy levels,
which normally occupies gives out light. So it's a way of generating light,
right? And the particular gas will give a particular wavelength of light.
I don't know what this is, may be air even. And the reason I don't know,
gets a characteristic discharge from a gas,
which depends on the identity of the gas and the pressure.
And since we don't know the pressure and we don't know the gas,
it's a bit difficult to guess there are measurements we might be able to do,
but we might damage the tubes.
And any way we didn't have the kids at the moment,
this equipment must be quite old because my grandfather,
if he was still alive would be 143 years old and he died
55 years ago.
So the very minimum is probably 70 or 80 years old could be a
hundred years old.
So the gas has been sealed inside the DAS for that time.
And the fact that they still work means they're still at low pressure
and air has not gone inside the tube from outside,
everything leaks slightly.
But the rate of leakage is so slow that the performance has not been affected.
And I find that pretty well.
The other thing which you can tell is that because the glass
and the liquid here glow,
when the discharge takes place,
it means that the gas is emitting UV light.
So presumably the tube going through here is either
glass that does not absorb UV light very strongly.
It could be quite thin glass,
or it may even be quartz there. If it's quartz,
it's a fantastic piece of glass blowing because quartz is not an easy material
to blue.
I once tried using this. I can't remember when,
when we used to have Tesla coils in the lamp,
but I haven't used it for 20 or 30 years at the
minimum, but then I thought that Neil would like to get his hands on it.
And I wasn't wrong.
What to me is remarkable is that these pieces of equipment,
which are made purely for entertainment,
they have no deep scientific value and were made
to entertain audiences perhaps a hundred years ago are still working
today and are still entertaining. People,
perhaps entertainment view definitely entertaining me,
but also pose intriguing questions. What is the liquid?
What is the glass made of and so on. And of course,
what immediately comes to mind is what techniques you could find to
identify these things without damaging the equipment.
I think that my grandfather would be quite
amused. I knew him though. He died when I was 11,
but I think he would be very amused that it was being sold to such a big
audience.
He couldn't possibly have imagined the number of people that would watch
this video, even if it's not very successful,
we're talking about thousands of people watching it.
And so I think it is really quite a
attribute to my grandfather,
that the items that he collected and now being shared with a big audience.